R. Ellis Frazier, Director, Producer, CEO at
BADHOUSE Studios: Don't get sucked into people's
own agendas of what they need.
You just make sure that you
serve the product, you serve the movie always.
Film Courage: I heard you say in another interview
that a common thing for a lot of filmmakers,
actors, screenwriters is that they
think their first film is going to
set the trajectory for the rest of their
career. They maybe get a lot of praise,
they walk the red carpet, people
are emailing and you think that it's
up from there and that it's actually
very humbling to see that it's not?
Frazier: Yes, I do. Certainly I was humbled, our
crew was humbled (our group). The first one we did
had Andy Garcia [La linea a.k.a. The Line movie,
2009] in it a whole bunch of people there's red
carpets, there was premieres, there was all kinds
of great screenings and everything else and the
Weinsteins are calling you, the agencies
are calling you and you realize that
we're not given in this world and this
universal film that we've decided to be in
there is no stability in it I mean there's
no the trajectory is what it becomes and
you have to make it. It never goes to easy
street and we were doing a lot of things
trying to thinking that we were trying
to get this bigger film made it's just
you're going to do this one the size and the
next one's going to be the next size well it
turned out the next one was half the size and
then the next one half the size of that. So
that is my filmmaking journey. It doesn't go like
that, it's all over the place and I realized that
we can go back to the original idea which is
just to keep working and not let anything get in
the way not let all the needs to set things up
here and set things up here and raise all this
money let's find a way to just keep making films
and add value and so my trajectory went through
this kind of organic film school because when
I was with the first film I didn't really
understand much about what was going on there was
a bunch of experts around me that knew everything
and they said you're the big boss and so you go
over there and you get an assistant and do all
this different stuff and it was really cool but
I didn't if I i didn't know everything that was
all the the different machinations of what was
happening and it cost us frankly if I would have
known that now i'd have been like wait a minute
you don't need that and this and that you could
just have that why are we paying for all three
but I didn't know any better and so so the the
you know I I wouldn't change a thing I learned
so much now I can do everything now I know
about all the different elements of the
film business it's funny sometimes we do
production services you see directors come in
and they don't know these things they don't know
but they just say I just want this and it's like
oh okay but you don't need that but but I want it
because they say we want it and everything
else but now I know what we want and need
it I can distill it down to what's on the screen
because at the end of the day if you want to
keep your budgets at the level that you can keep
working consistently in independent film you have
to just worry about what's on that screen because
what's behind it may not it might not always be
very pretty to watch the sausage being made but
as long as we get what we want on the screen
then that's what matters as long as we get into
the edit and we can have everything we need that's
what that's what counts and so we do sometimes
smaller films now we do a little bit larger films
and we can do them all and we're comfortable at
all budget levels and sometimes it's about the
expectations that people have and the optics you
need to create for a client which is all money I
tell them that too I said if you let us do it and
you're not worried about it then we can do it for
less if you're there watching us everything is
going to be a little more because it's our job
to make sure that the optics are are correct and
you have a certain type of experience that you're
expecting and you said you had people maybe
well-meaning in your ear saying it needs to
be this way and so maybe more money was spent
or things were done in a different way how much
exposure to the industry did you have growing up
you said you lived in la briefly or I did I had
almost none just especially not production I had
been on working for a guy by name Ronald Shusett
for a while who's the writer producer of alien
total recall minority report and I was on the
development side with him and working with his
management to get some projects off the ground
but as far as onset production it was just
this huge mystery to me and it feels glamorous
it's like you're on set and all these things are
going on and all these people with the headphones
and and they're calling you sir and it's it's
really intoxicating but I but so but I had
really no real idea of what was what was going
on other than the basic leadership stuff okay I
make sure that everybody's paid and
things of that sort but as far as
knowing that the intricate details of production
I really didn't know much at all and and
and but you need to know you need to know a lot
because if people will tell you you need this
kind of camera and you need these things with the
camera you and this and that and this and that
and you're doing a shot that could be
done on sticks with a doorway dolly
and you don't always need everything they're
talking about you need so in order for you
to be able to look at them squint out and say
please don't tell me you need that because I know
we don't need it I know exactly what we need
and we can just do it like that so this is
part of that learning process over
failure and all the things that you
learn through a trial and error and failure
frankly and so for a first film a director
producer may have to take it a little bit and nod
their head and then maybe after what third film
they can have that conversation yeah first
film is you're nervous half the time you just
it's a lot of pressure to direct a film
and it's more pressure than I think people
are think it's going to be I've seen it
drive people literally crazy and they just
go crazy and just start doing crazy things and
saying crazy things and I'll tell you you know
once you get that through through that process
then you at least you can get through it that you
can get through it emotionally and you learn a lot
from that and your second third projects yeah then
you can start to tell people hey I know what we
need I know what we need I know we don't need that
and you learn to listen to people around
you that you trust and make sure that you
don't get sucked into people's own agendas
of what they need you just make sure that you
serve the product you serve the movie
always and you just keep that in mind
always serving the final product you serve the
final edit more than you do getting all this
crazy outside coverage that that you'll
never need so but that comes from experience
and it has to be a full process meaning
through the edit because the edit
editing is the most important thing I've learned
is editing because what that teaches you is what
you need and what you don't need I don't
know if you just watch a cut of your film
six months after you shoot it you don't know how
they made those decisions to get to there if you
sit there with the editor okay we're going to go
from here geogra-create the geography of the room
we're going to get cut into coverage and what
is the point of the film we're going to have to
the shake hands let's get that on an
insert or a special and then you cut
back out to the geography if you when you edit
you learn that so when you're in there filming
that that's what you need and so you don't have
to beat up your actors with something on some shot
list or a lot of storyboards that maybe somebody
might have done for you you can just say I got
it and a lot of people will thank you for that
is there a way to handle agendas with finesse
yeah well I personally have a very calm
directing style and producing style
I don't get banana shape but you try to listen
to what they are saying and you listen to it
and then you have to just say well I just we don't
need that or we do need it if they have an agenda
meaning if they're thinking hey this is going
to be a shot for my reel as a DP or something
I want the shot for your reel too if we
can afford it and if we have time and if
it makes sense other than that we're going
to have a shot for the end cut of the movie
and and so you just have to be firm but if people
look at you and you're talking to them they'll
know if what you're talking about or not it's very
hard to look at somebody and say hey I know that
we need this and that and that and this or this
shot and this and that and I look at him and say
no we don't we don't need it and we've
got everything we need on the scene
I know you want the big boom up dolly down
cross over push in I get I want that too but
we got to move on so so you just be kind about it
I don't yell or anything like that but you must
assert your authority on a set because there's
too much going on to not have a clear line of
authority and so I make sure that I do that with
kindness but with but I'm relatively firm about
it do you think the agendas are stronger in Los
Angeles or in Mexico or they're different agendas
this is an opinion very much
stronger in Los Angeles you know
when you have American crew I’ve done scenes
here days of filming here it's a very very
different thing you get people that are very
much concerned about how they're going to look
be perceived be blamed things of that sort
and they'll you'll hear a lot in the states of
hey this is going to have my name on it
so it's gotta I don't feel comfortable
with this my name's on there as the gaffer so
I need to make sure that the lighting's right
i don't find that in Mexico at all
and I've worked with a few crews there
they it's just the work ethic is a little bit
different they defer to the to the director
I think a little bit more but then look if you're
going to build a career in la you've got to get
a real you got to get a bunch of different stuff
going on and it's important you you have to keep
your the quality of your work a certain level and
you have to keep your reputation as somebody easy
to work with at a certain level and that your work
is done well you can't well that gaffer completely
messed up the lighting then you may never work
again or it might be difficult to work again so
so there's a lot more pressures I don't blame them
for it it's but it's but it's different and and
I do when you're a gaffer or whatever has their
own website in their own real that's like okay
that's but that shows that look that's
what they're kind of supposed to do
they're supposed to get themselves out there but
when you're talking about because all this is
fixed with a lot of money if you have a
huge budget then you can have those people
but when you're when that you're going to be in
the trenches of an indie it's going to get sticky
that everything's not going to go
perfect then you have to loyalty and
loyalty to the project and the product
has to take precedent I have a saying
and that's that I always protect
the film over protecting myself
I protect the project that means I gotta
take a lot of crap sometimes a lot of abuse
but it has to always what I'm doing has to
always serve the final product and if I have
to take a little bit of someone yelling at
me whatever the case is then I'll take it
I find that sometimes in la there's a lot of
fighting and bickering sometimes I'm not saying
all the time but sometimes and they just people
are upset and disguise yelling at this guy and
this guy and this that but another reason I think
that is is because a lot of times you'll go on to
a set and the gaffer will never have work with
the grip and the sound boom guy never worked
with the sound mixer it's like everybody comes
in for like and then gets used to each other
in Mexico our crew is set we work together
all the time so we it's like a shorthand so
so we know everybody's temperament and you
you learn to weed out people that don't have
the correct temperament for what we're trying
to do so once you do your tenth film or so
where you're where your where your weak points
are and and then your strong points are so you say
you always have you always have the ability to do
the film with just a very small core group and so
and that protects the film you let
in certain films maybe in the states
one or two people go it's like the film can't
be done that day what I'm saying we we can
switch out loot positions and places and parts
so it all makes sense so yeah I mean at the end
of the day it's much different in my opinion
much different from Los Angeles to Mexico but
it's just different it doesn't mean it's better
or worse it's just different so but for the money
that we try to put everything on the screen so we
just try to keep it as streamlined as possible.
Have you had setbacks in your career
where you had to start from square one?